this program is brought to you by Emory
University you can't even accept
yourself you know that you can suggest
appearance well the story of the x-men
is the story of a reviled minority and
it really isn't even so much about their
mutant powers as it is about a kind of a
dramatic representation of what happens
when there's a group that's feared by
the majority and that really is the
engine the dynamic engine that runs the
x-men scientifically what's interesting
about x-men is that in often in majority
minority relationships you're talking
about some physiological difference
racial difference ethnic difference so
they created one through genetics of
course genetically the x-men make no
sense there's just no way that through
even dramatic mutation you can for
example have a normal human being give
birth to a human being with wings a
bird's wing or any animals wing as many
many many genes associated with it
through all kinds of trial and error and
x-men born with eyes that shoot laser
beams and these kinds of things are
other ly implausible as sudden mutations
on the other hand they're completely
plausible as bio technological
developments and we're already
developing in different ways some of the
kinds of powers that the x-men
demonstrate there are genetic
engineering possibilities for human
beings somewhere down the line that
would increase things like memory
perhaps attention maybe even strength
not to superhuman levels but to perhaps
mimic the best achievements of the
species
even insofar as we might someday be able
to borrow traits from animals we're
still never going to reach superhuman
abilities we don't know how to create
muscles that exceed the muscles of the
strongest creatures on earth muscles are
made of flesh and have a finite bearing
load and things like that it's only when
you combine them with technology can you
really talk about truly extraordinary
types of powers right now it would
probably be theoretically possible to
create things like glow-in-the-dark
humans the bioluminescent genes that we
use now routinely in science as markers
as genetic markers have already been
used in mammals and monkeys to create
animals that express that gene in every
cell in their body so they glow
the thing that stops us from putting
these kinds of technologies to human
beings are not technical limitations but
ethical limitations we really don't know
what the impact of messing with the
human genome in that way might be and
moreover why why would you want to
create a human that glows in the dark
does that have any function or is it
just curiosity and one of the great
challenges to us is how do we resist the
temptation to use genetic technologies
and that we master in human beings for
reasons that are less than life-saving
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University